hello good afternoon police have
launched an investigation into multiple
allegations of child sex offenses at a
nursery in Devon a male employee at the
jack-and-jill nursery until kee was
arrested in July after a child alerted
their parents to an incident police have
looked through more than 250 hours of
CCTV footage and have identified a
number of potential victims aged between
two and five our correspondent Dan
Whitehead is in Torquay hello to you Dan
what more can you tell us about the
allegations yes this is an investigation
which started as an allegation of an
incident against one child here at the
jack-and-jill childcare nursery in
Torquay it has now been widened to
include multiple potential offences of a
child of childhood sexual offences
against children and it follows an
investigation which began at the end of
July when a male employee here at the
nursery was arrested by police on
suspicion of sexual assault and over the
last couple of months officers from
Devon and Cornwall Police have been
trawling through more than 250 hours of
CCTV from multiple cameras inside the
nursery behind me here and during that
investigation they say they have
identified a number of children aged
between two and five who are potential
victims of contact offences of a sexual
nature
now police told me in the last few hours
that they have contacted around a
hundred families who had children at the
nursery at the time that this male
employee was staff here and also in the
subsequent months after he was suspended
when he was arrested at the end of July
now the nursery is closed off stead the
Education regulator carried out a number
of inspections over the last couple of
months since the allegation and on the
24th of October so 12 days ago they
ruled clearly that the nursery had not
been meeting its safeguarding measures
and removed its registration from their
board and have now closed the
nursery the families of the children
have had to find alternative childcare
devon and cornwall police no stranger to
stories of this nature you may remember
ten years ago the little Ted nursery in
Plymouth where Vanessa George was jailed
for 10 years for taking photographs
indecent images of very young children a
pedophile ring was involved in that that
incidents Vanessa Jorge was released a
couple of months ago I have been
chatting to Detective Chief Inspector
James Stark who was keen to stress that
this is a very different type of
incident and investigation I like to
stress that these actions are due to one
lone individual and there's no evidence
to suggest any involvement of images
being shared or distributed their
contact defenses by the one employee at
the nursery
speaking Sioux locals in this very
residential area in Torquay they of
course speak of their shock many they do
say that this is a very well-regarded
nursery and they feel for the family
which runs this nursery and has had to
close it while this investigation
obviously continues there is a
multi-agency approach to this
investigation from the council Child
Support Services they have set up a
helpline for families who are concerned
and police say they have had a number of
phone calls from parents worried that
their children may be involved in this
incident okay Dan Whitehead parent or
key for us thank you